abu dhabi
allez-y monsieur les yeux sur vous
appuyez dessus et a pas vous donner la
pièce
d'accord je regarde genre
boudet quoi la toile allez je vous ai
levé les essuie glaces comme ça vous
donnerez la pièce après quand vous aurez
fini de nettoyer
vous mettez du désert on est obligé de
vérifier les gens sont tellement cons
les feuilles m'a dit super dans les
diesels à versements quand je parle à
penser à ma petite pièce oubliée parce
qu'il ya plein de gens qui oublient
savoir jouer à ces petites bagnoles
attendait cecop applicables
c'est bien un pilier lg moins chère
c'est le diesel
j'ai mis 5 mondiale de diesel
avancez vous allez tomber en panne il
faut faire la vidange la même chez
désolé non non c'est un coup de vis en
france je les fais tout à l'heure ça
c'est pas un énorme
je plaisante pas je me du diesel
monsieur tanner avancer on va on va on
va vite nettoyer interview water
sénescence oh merde merde merde merde
merde j'ai mis 5 handball il faut faire
la vidange
ils vont vous le faire même ça va nous
coûter 1000 francs et là ils vont venir
tout changer ça va vous coûter 1000
francs et avec nos pouvoirs s'est pas
donné non plus combien vous allez
messieurs la wii pouviez pas faire le
plein ça convient que 130 balles cette
merde
bon allez payer et je puis vous voir ici
un attendait mais descend pas chez toi
servi à ta poubelle et ce qu'il veut
c'est mon métier ne faisait pas d'où ça
vient me suis aujourd'hui c'est quoi
c'est une rolls peut-être bien comment
elle est crade
est ce qu'on a dans l'est qu'elle soit
alors ok prenez le comme ça je vais vous
dire une bonne chose
les points total c'est plein de points
c'est pas propre au total peut-être vous
êtes un jeune couple vous attendez que
ça pour faire un trousseau et tient le
pin se voit le pin's hop tu vois plus je
vous laisse je vais en mettre un petit
coup sur le pare-brise ballon descendez
alors après d'abord je vous en met un
petit coup sur le pare-brise indécents
des as dont je me sens le pare brise
allez-y management met un petit coup de
barre bouazzi la première bouche de
métro ici la plus proche alors vous
voulez aller où on veut aller
c'est dans le vide 9e à l'hôpital
rothschild d'agneau losique quel service
totalement du professeur
aucune idée c'est pas le sait pour qui
vous avez de la famille l'amérique et
nous faire il a quoi une
maintenant il a un problème neurologique
au niveau des yeux et la prune
et est-ce qu'on lui a donné ok et qu'est
ce qu'il veut comme traitement il est
rien bon je vois bien le professeur là
pour voir un peu le traitement là parce
que c'est normal qu'il ait pas eu de
chien avec ma mère on va lui rendre
visite
c'est maintenant c'est peut-être buttes
chaumont par là votre avis ouais mais ça
m'inquiète qu'il n'est pas un traitement
parce que même en observation il pourra
lui donner du clan védrines trois points
par jour
et puis j'aime bien le professeur l'a
quand même c'est plus tranquille parce
que ça m'inquiète c'est quoi vous êtes
numéro deux nord de la chance c'est quoi
il s'appelle qu'on appelait monsieur est
la vache ou américaines messieurs
monsieur éviter d'être comme ça ça fait
d un peu le coude
soyez plus naturelle voyaient voilà
c'est passé c'est la direction qui me
demande monsieur direction le patron
michel mouillart je me dis bah ouais il
me dit le type est un genre je vais
finir en direction est
être vu comme ça non avec quatre jours
tapo pas marche pas dessus
vous n'êtes pas [__] tu vas tout
provient non pas d'hôpital a depuis tout
à l'heure ndi le mec là il est un genre
tout cas veut bien faire c'est dingue
les gens ils sont précaires non plus n'a
dévié derrière
ouais je suis en train de mettre les
sens cela dit c'est vrai que quand on
vous voit comme ça un rien ça fait un
peu voilé bourrer la gueule à neutre
stage avec toi au libouli golf sur une
feuille à 3000 litres par mois
eh bien je te fais le jeu te fuit le
pays attend je te file de poule soit non
non mais c'est une blague
messieurs
ce qui était drôle si avec le directeur
de cette pompe était adorable nous a
reçus comme des rois on l'a fait chier
toute l'algérie ne l'a vraiment au pays
sa cassure est qu il pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux